hello everyone good afternoon almost to
the end here right 11 o'clock tonight
right no that's something else so yeah
my name is Jimmy Bogart you can find me
on twitter @ @j bogart this presentation
as well the samples will be in my github
and get out that comm / je Bogart and
you can find me blog about this and
other topics at Jimmy Bogart comm and
for my day job I do a lot of this kind
of stuff at a consultant coming out of
Texas called Hut spring so me personally
I've actually been doing a CI HDD for
databases for quite a long time probably
like 15 16 years now or so so a lot of
this is gonna be some more stories and
lessons learned about doing these kinds
of activities over all the different
kinds of ways you can possibly do it
over the years and one of the very first
lessons I learned when trying to get
started with CI in cd4 databases was to
be kind to your DBA s because their
company prefers their data to your code
like if they lost your code they
wouldn't care but if they lost the data
they'd be really really upset so be be
kind to your DBA s so if I look at just
kind of normalcy ICD processes it's like
the typical kind of C ICD processes are
pretty simple it basically starts out
with a developer who wants to write some
code the developer makes them change to
some code and push this it up to github
and then after we pushed up to github
then something takes that coat and
perform some kind of build around it
right and then after the build you put
some kind of artifact an artifact gets
pushed out again to some kind of some
kind of CD tool then finally it's going
to push your code out into production
now I have it I think I'm supposed to
change the logos from Azure pipelines to
github actions but I didn't quite get
that done in time so this is actually
pretty straightforward thing to do like
all the tooling all the stuff makes this
sort of thing really really easy in fact
I got this entire pipeline you can you
can basically do all from inside
something like Visual Studio you can
right click start doing stuff and it'll
automate this entire pipeline for you
and the reason why this is super easy
for us to do is because applications are
ideally stateless that is it is really
easy for us to create and
story them because we have to worry
about the application holding on to any
kind of state but databases aren't like
databases are by their nature stay full
right that's where we put our
information so that means that it's much
much easier for us to screw that up
because it's sitting there waiting for
us to screw it up over there it also
means that data screw ups are much much
harder to recover from because we may
not have an ability to rewind time and
go back in time and if I had this I've
had this happened before where I screwed
up something in data and production and
then we had to go through that whole
like recovery process and try to get our
backups to make to put State back to our
used to be and it's just a very painful
process whereas something like I screwed
up an application or had a bug I can fix
it pretty quickly and get it out there
and not really worry about what what is
going on at that point in time I do
notice that you won't really get fired
for killing an application but you will
get fired for killing a database I know
ok so there's there's a lot more risk
inherent with changing a database over
changing an application because of the
stateful nature and a lot of companies I
work with treat that risk as a danger
which means like then we just won't
change our database at all because any
kind of change has all this sort of
downstream implications but we we if we
want our database to be able to grow
with the business and be able to evolve
with a business and we need to be able
to change our database over time and we
want to have the same rigor applied to
the process as we put in changing and
deploying our applications over time to
our database as well we don't want to be
paralyzed by fear and just say we're
going to throw up our hands and just not
do anything and so we want to have some
kind of continuous integration and
delivery process for our databases now a
lot of customers customers I work with
who have like the database and sometimes
it's even called the database that sits
in the middle of their enterprise they
have some really arcane change
management processes where has to go
like 3 17 different levels of approvals
and then at the end you find out like
it's actually just one DBA running the
script in production but we don't wanna
do that right we don't want to have some
mistake make the local news because we
did something wrong
and you've probably seen this sometimes
right like besides all the security
holes that get found out and published
about I need everyone so I would find
some news article that's like someone
had access to production database and
accidentally deleted the entire database
that still happens these days and that
happens because we're allowing humans to
have access to run these queries but we
don't want to do that we don't want to
have a human involved in this process it
could potentially screw things up for
everybody so we need a way to be able to
safely automate changes to our database
and allow that to automation strategy to
be able to handle any kind of situation
we throw at it now I see two main
approaches one I vastly prefer and one
that other people prefer for some reason
and those are desired state
configuration or DSC and migrations
there's a lot of tools out there for a
desired state configuration or DSC one
of the more popular ones in the
Microsoft world is the database projects
inside of Visual Studio so you say right
click create database project another
very popular one is from Red Gate which
is sequel compare and the general idea
behind design state configuration is you
have the state of word as today and you
want it to get to the state that you
want it to be and so you you you you
picture out here's the state I want it
to be and then some tool takes the diff
between those two things and tries to
figure out how to take your sketch or
the existing state in production and
then get that migrated from what you're
telling it it needs to be so it needs to
be able to be smart enough to be able to
detect all the different changes that
you've made generate that script on the
fly and then be able to actually deploy
it out there now I've used those tools
quite a bit and they are very
intelligent smart tools especially with
the Redgate tools they're just like
absolutely amazing and what they can do
but the problem is that they introduce
the possibility of failure because it
can't detect every single kind of change
that you could that you could throw at
it we have situations where we're not
just migrating schema we're also
migrating data at the same time and
those kinds of tools just aren't smart
enough or don't allow you to be able to
say ok when you perform this kind of
upgrade also run these extra sort of the
things at the same time and oftentimes
what you won't know about the need to
have a manual intervention until you
actually try to run the tool and so what
I want to have happen though is a
completely automated process for my
deployment from n2n application and
database and if it's some tool out there
that we're using that introduces the
possibility of needing manual
intervention well then that kind of
destroys the the whole idea of
continuous delivery where I don't have
any kind of human involved in that
process now they're probably already out
there right now that I have had success
with these tools and I'm not telling you
not to use those but anytime I have one
of these tools that requires some kind
of human intervention we can end up in
situations like this we're like okay we
got this existing thing that looks okay
but something went wrong and now a human
intervened and here's what we end up
with so these tools aren't perfect for
automating change detection and
deployments they're very very very good
but they're not perfect and anything
that's not perfect there's could require
human intervention is that possibility
that something can get screwed up I also
find that the further that the further
the drift the much more difficult these
tools have to do with it and I've been
bitten encountered situations where
sometimes I'm deploying some system out
to some remote environment whether it's
some remote location or something that's
just really physically hard to get to if
I'd systems were you have to get in a
helicopter to be able to get out into
the middle of the Gulf to be able to
take your thumb drive stick it in and
perform the upgrade and no one's had
been on that helicopter for two years
and so it's been a very long time since
I've done any kind of upgrade so in
these kinds of automated tools that just
kind of look at the before and after and
try to figure it out on the fly really
fall down in cases where there could be
a long time between my different
deployments so that's where database my
creations come into play and database
migrations instead of me having like a
before-and-after picture and just
figuring it out on the fly
instead I explicitly tell the tool these
are the steps I want you to perform to
get your database from one from one
version to the next and very often what
we'll do is include both of those things
together we'll include the data changes
necessary to be able to change the
application and whatever schema changes
are necessary to be able to perform the
migration and those two things together
then
are part of that single single source
control commit so I know in my source
control at any point in time exactly
what version my database is up against
so with this sort of system it's not
just like I can go back and time to see
what the database looks like at here but
I can have a database that as many many
versions out of dates and the migrations
are just applied one at a time until
that database is finally at the version
that I expect it to be so for these
migration tools to work they need three
things they need a way to capture the
changes that you want to perform so Yoon
somebody to describe the changes that
you want to make on the database they
need a way to then apply those changes
on the target database and finally they
need have some way to remember the
changes that you've made to ensure that
I don't accidentally make the same
change twice or somehow get out of whack
or out of date with the database I'm
trying to effect no database migrations
have been around for quite a long time I
saw them like kind of simultaneously
invented about the same time but you see
a lot of agile teams and processes
really center around database migrations
as the safest way to be able to take one
database from one version to the next
now I'm a dotnet developer and we got
migrations basically last I guess like
everything else in the world and some of
the tools we see out there are pretty
popular one of them is entity framework
migrations anybody framework migrations
is a code based migration tool that is
there's some kind of DSL or
domain-specific language that I used to
describe the change I want in this case
it's just c-sharp code and although the
popular migration tools are like this
like rails migrations for Ruby on Rails
is a fairly similar kind of concept
Django has a similar kind of thing as
well the problem is this is entity
framework migrations right and in order
to get migrations approved I have to
talk to the database administrator and
DBAs love ORM z-- right and what they
really love is like hey this this tool I
hate there's another tool that's
completely also hide the sequel that
you're intending to run at the most
important time which is deployment and
so I've never actually gotten this kind
of migration strategy ever approved by
any kind of DBA so this is not very DBA
friendly
now one tool that is quite DBA friendly
is a red gate tool called sequel change
automation this is the third different
name they've had for this tool but it is
a complete change automation migration
utility it allows you both to use the
other kind of red gate tools behind the
scenes to figure out what schema changes
are have happened and then does like
your normal kind of migration process to
be able to push it out into production
I've also used this in a couple clients
as well the big problem we saw with this
though that's not very wallet friendly
because they don't sell that thing by
itself and so every single person on the
team needs that that like the most
expensive red gate license I mean I love
their tooling but not everyone needs to
pay like that much money for just to run
migrations and so although it's very a
very robust tool it's I still have a
very hard time with my clients trying to
justify the entire sequel tool belt for
every single person on the team so with
those two options we much prefer
something that is that is DBA friendly
and also very easy to automate it's the
tool that I use is not a one called
roundhouse now around house the reason
why I like it is one its sequel centric
so the scripts that you write are sequel
not like some other DSL that gets
translated in sequel and so a lot of
times we pair up DBAs with our
developers to actually author those
sequel scripts for us like it's not
really that hard to write DML statements
but they may be able to author them in a
more efficient manner or maybe they have
some other things they have to do as
part of the migration process it has
lots of dotnet lots of a database
support so we've used it for pretty much
anything we can throw it whether it's
sequel server sequel a zero or whole my
sequel Postgres it just supports all
those different kind of things and
because it's based on Dianetics
cross-platform so I can run it as part
of a Linux build a Mac build or my
windows build as well so before we get
too far into there I want to take a step
back and say there's there's one step of
the process we want to make sure we
still have as part of that which is the
very first part of this process which is
the developer experience we want to make
sure that they're involved in the entire
continuous integration process so what
things do we need to put in place to
enable
to have a robust robust continuous
integration process and big thing we're
trying to do here is allow the developer
to safely make changes to the database
be able to run and test that locally
before they actually push it out to a CI
environment or out to production and the
big thing we want to do here is make
sure that every single environment has
its own logical database one of the
things I see developers often do is like
they have like the database which is the
big monolithic database that everyone
connects to and they had like these
weird replicated versions that everyone
still tries to connect and the reforms I
see with that approach is it's very hard
to make sure that you don't accidentally
overwrite someone else's changes so one
of these I try to do is to make sure
that every single developer has their
own individual local dev database and a
local test database and by ensuring that
we have isolated databases per
individual developer we make sure that
the Dover can make those changes in
isolation before they even commit the
code before it actually goes out the
door so want to show a quick demo of
this just to see what it looks like to
have a local database running with my
individual developer somewhere you go
ahead and stop and switch over to Visual
Studio
okay so what I've got here is just a an
application but this application has an
actual database behind the scenes so we
we can run it we can see it's got all
this like actual model behind the scenes
and what I want to do is to make some
kind of change to this application so in
this case it's like a simple if I want
to make a simple change something like
just adding a field to the screen I
won't have something that actually means
that I need to have some kind of
database change along with that as well
okay so probably the easiest thing to do
is just add some fields to one of these
items so what I'd like to do is take one
of the models and just add some property
to here what I want to do is find out
how easy or difficult it is for me to
just add some field to something that
gets persisted and then all the
different places that need to happen as
part of that so I've got here just you
know just this is a just one of the
Microsoft sample applications that I
borrow because it's easier for me to
just use what's already there I don't do
something like let's add something like
pet name to this property or to this
class so that's not going to be
sufficient for me to have this
application actually run right we have
to we have to still do things like add
fields to the screens so let's do that
on the page where I see all the list of
students
I'll go add their pet name now see it on
the screen
and I'll need to add it to the list of
results on the screen as well so we'll
go ahead a pet name there and now I can
see the lists of pets for this ended
individual person so if I ran this
though right now the application still
wouldn't work because the application
doesn't know that I've added this field
and that should be backed by something
in the database as well and so that's
where migrations come into play so the
tool that I'm using roundhouse allows me
to author sequel scripts and in this
case I'm just going to put them in a
special folder called up and up are all
the scripts - well to upgrade the
database from one version to the next so
I'm just going to duplicate my older one
and sheet and I'll call it something
special and pet name - student and as
part of this I will include the DML to
be able to describe how I should change
this table so in this case I'll say I
need to add pet name and we'll just
leave it as in var car 100 because why
not
okay now as part of this though some
people may not have a pet name already
and so I can decide at this point in
time do I also want to include any kind
of data migrations to take an account
that this information may not already
exist so as part of this I can also do
something like update person
person set that name equal to I don't
know Roger okay so in addition to me
actually changing the database schema
I'm also going to be filling in some
information along with that process so
now I need to actually run these
migrations now this is where it comes to
like what what makes most sense for the
individual team now some of the tools
out there like EF migrations have
powershell commandlets do things i've
also seen some wonky things like the
first time you run the application
it'll also try to migrate the database
but again that's one of those things
that my DBAs will not allow me to do
like migrate the database and make DML
changes when i just run the thing they
want to be able to like I want to know
exactly what's gonna be run and I want
to be to have the ability to try that
out myself before you just actually ship
this out into production
alright so to do so I'm gonna go ahead
and run my local build and as part of my
local build it's not only going to like
restore compile run and run tests it is
also going to run my overall migrations
so we'll go ahead and let this go and
and watch it do the the migrations thing
and while that's going I'm going to pop
open the actual script itself so this is
my build script and one of the parts of
my build script I have as part of kind
of doing the initial installation is
installing this global tool for round
house
so round house comes in a variety of
different formats and one of the ways
you can use it is with a dinette global
tool so this way I say go ahead and up
star update which also will install it
if it's not there
this tool dotnet - round house and then
from there I can use an RH command let
me bump up the font way bit there we go
in that round house command I'm telling
it to migrate each individual database
that I'm interested in so the first one
is going to do is migrate my local dev
database
so that's that initial one right there
and I tell the folder in which to look
for the actual and right migration
scripts which is this app data folder
and then finally I tell it what to
connect to so I'm saying go ahead and
connect to ms local DB that would be
whatever you want it to be locally and
then for my test database I do something
a little bit different
my Testament database actually drop it
and recreate it every single time and
the reason why I'm doing this is just to
ensure that I don't have any inadvertent
bugs that only show up in my scripts if
I migrate versus do a new one from
scratch so this is just kind of a
backdrop for me to make sure that I
haven't screwed anything up with my
script okay it looks like my build
succeeded and if I scroll up just a
little bit we'll see down here it's
running those two scripts against my
local database for the test one I scroll
up a little bit more will see that it
actually skipped the previous script
that had already run and it is running
the second one that is actually against
that that is new and I just created
right here so behind the scenes that's
like the stupidest thing that could
possibly work but it has some more some
more intelligent it's part of it so one
of the things you can run into is a
developer changing a script which is a
bad idea so I've got one over here and
say actually you know what I didn't like
Roger we want to have like you know no
pet sorry
right like oh we made a mistake with our
script let's go ahead and change that if
I were to run this again we're actually
gonna get an error because I've changed
a script that should only run one time
that's something that important that
migration utilities need up taking
account is if migration scripts are only
to be able to run in one direction if
there's something that someone changed
as part of that script
then I don't know what what to do and
it's just gonna go ahead and blow up and
say up you you've you've done something
to change the script and now I can't
tell what I'm supposed to do and you
need to go ahead and fix that and the
way it does this is pretty
straightforward
as part of running the migrations again
it's like the stupidest thing that could
possibly work
what it'll do is every single script
that it runs it just has another
database table that records all the
scripts that you've created and so as
part of that not just including the
script name is a hash of the file itself
so if you change that file and screw it
up the hash changes and that's how it
detects that you've screwed something up
and now I need to blow up and fix it
so let's fix that let's go back to where
you were Roger and everything should
work again hopefully now one of the
things we wanted to do is part of local
to continuous integration were tests as
well so in order to show one quick test
to show how you can still use a local
test database to make sure that
everything in math location runs
successfully so as part of this one
we've got some tests to edit student
information and we'll go through the
whole thing but one of the things I did
want to highlight as part of running
this test there's a lot of different
ways I see folks try to run integration
tests to make sure that my application
will actually run successfully in
production one of these I like to do
though is to ensure that that
integration test matches as much as
possible how the
user actually interacts with this
application of production so instead of
doing things like rolling back
transactions or weird things like that
this integration test will connect to an
actual live database it will perform a
series of actions and each ones of these
actions each one of these actions like
here and here
those are actually full round-trip
transactions to ensure that my
integration test matches as much as
possible what we see in production with
a real user using this application so by
the time my my tests succeed then I
should have the greatest amount of
confidence that my application is
successful because I've made the change
locally I've got a local test database
it runs against it as if it would be in
production and then the build is green
okay so I'm going ahead and commit these
changes favorite pet name we didn't
actually run the application let's look
let's do that
let's run this and see if we can
actually see the pet names show up here
now I think I was supposed to actually
write a test that fails and do the whole
TD dance but I don't really feel like
doing that so we're just gonna go you
know we'll just do it live here whatever
so I filled it with in filled it with
some dummy data so if I go to the list
of students we should see a new column
show up where they're where their pet
name is over there name of Roger I did
forget to put the header up there but I
can fix that later all right so let's go
ahead and push those changes up and talk
about the next step in the process so
I've made my changes everything looks
good locally I authored my migration
script I pushed up the changes well the
next step is going to be my build step
to build my changes and run those
changes and those tests against again
some kind of local database now this is
the kind of difficult part I find and it
really depends on what my application is
actually doing so in some cases where
I'm in a Greenfield application it's
relatively easy for me to build out a
kind of clean local test database in my
CI environment but that's not always the
case in some cases we have some kind of
shared test database that chews across
all of my test runs because maybe it's
filled with some production like data
that I have to run against to ensure
that my system runs against that kind of
real-world data so that part kind of
depends but I do find that most of the
CI most of the CI tools out there do
have the ability to run a some kind of
pre-built image that has databases on
there that you can run against all right
so let's see how that works and again I
haven't switched this over to github
actions like I guess I was supposed to
use so this is still just running
against Azure pipelines so it's trying
to stop that and I'm gonna switch over
to Azure pipelines
okay hopefully given kin of actions to
be faster than this because take a
little bit of time for my CI bill to run
but I have to have so like what what
does my CI build need to actually look
like between how it looks locally versus
how it works in running in a CI tool so
what I like to do is try to make that
make my local build as much as possible
match what I would expect to see in the
CI environment so instead of my CI
environment having all these different
steps to perform instead what I'll do is
let me go ahead and show the template
for this the build that it's going to
run is actually going to be the exact
same build script that I would run
locally that way I can make sure that if
something goes wrong with my CI build
well I'm running the exact same script
locally so it should be very easy to do
to debug any kind of differences or
problems I may run into this is kind of
a controversial topic I don't really
care that much one way or the other just
I want to make sure that if something
goes wrong that I have some way to
figure out how to fix it now the only
big difference is I need to have some
way to connect to test databases when I
run my script and so I might have some
extra step of like creating a specific
test database instances or connecting to
something that I've already built out in
that environment all right let's see if
this thing actually finished nope still
going of course so the build script that
we've got going is fairly strobe for
it's basically a bunch of dotnet
commands it's just dotnet clean build my
database migrations test and then
publish now the last piece in this
puzzle is going to be how do I take the
migration scripts that I have created
and then be able to deploy them out into
different environments and so that's my
last step in the process here but in my
corporate environments I don't just have
one environment I'm deploying to I
typically have multiple environments in
this case I've got like a dev and
production one and so there's not just
like a final step of just push out the
changes I need to be able to
automate the deployment out into each of
these individual environments so this
space I had to figure out okay deploying
the application is relatively easy but
how do we how do I deploy the database
migration changes how do I deploy and
run that tool against these different
environments so go ahead and show how we
do that so the first piece of the puzzle
is at the end of a build there's going
to be some kind of artifact created so
as part of that artifact I can include
the sequel change scripts as part of my
overall deployment and so in my
application what I've done is I just
stuck my sequel scripts in this special
app data folder and I know that's a
special folder because as your app
services recognizes that as a special
folder where it won't like allow any
kind of access to so it seems like a
safe place to go ahead and put my
migration scripts and then as part of
the deployment in the build at the
bottom here whenever it publishes out
the application I'm going to copy over
all the tools I need in order to
actually deploy this system so I've got
this round house the round house
executable tool and all of the scripts
that I've included so all those things
then get copied out into into and to the
deployed folder so when you publish the
application it's got both the scripts
and the running application that it can
run in the deployment so let's see if
that actually finished it should be
finished pretty soon let's see so last
one took five minutes and this one is
going on five minutes so it should be
done pretty soon but let's go look at
the log output to see what we can see
here - oh it did finish all right so
yeah as part of the build we can see
down here somewhere down here it should
see up there's the tool that's running
our migrations against MS sequel local
DB so again this matches almost exactly
what we have in our local environments
is going to be in our CI environment as
well again anything I can eliminate
between differences in those
environments just ensures that it can
catch those failures before I even
commit
the code out okay the next part is going
to be actually pushing this code out in
projection so I've got two applications
running I've got the dev let's see if
it's actually released so it's running
the deployment in progress and behind
the scenes what is this doing edit
pipeline it's triggering off that's
turning off the release and it's going
to automatically deploy out into my dev
environment but the dev environment is
going to be to individual tasks for its
deployment the first one is going to be
deploying the azure app service that's
like just straightforward as your app
service but the second part is going to
be migrating the database and migrating
the database is just going to be a
PowerShell script that is going to run
the round house tool so the round house
tool just use the same kinds of
arguments that I would use in my local
environments I use here as well with the
slight change that I'm going to make
sure that the the connection string it's
going to use to connect to the database
is passed in via secret as opposed to
like hard-coded inside of here so won't
sure that because well then you'll be
able to see my connection string but
it's there trust me that's being passed
in right here so as part of that it's
running the deployment of my application
and running the migration and everything
succeeds saw five refresh my dev sites
we should see the version update at the
bottom and if I go to the list of
students know version 50 anyone should
see again that's Roger over there on the
right and of course I want to now push
this out into production then I can go
back up to this build
alright the release and approve it and
now it will actually get it Boyd into
production so in this case I do have a
manual approval process but the actual
deployment itself is 100% automated so
with this approach the sequel based
approach it ensures that the scripts
that I'm running I know exactly what the
going to run and exactly the effect is
going to have on my target system and so
that kind of approach just ensures that
I have a I have complete control over
exactly how my system is going to get
upgraded now that's just kind of like
the basic migration stuff but what
happens when we kind of turn this up to
eleven and really start to do things at
a much more massive scale those kinds of
scripts that we saw earlier like just
alter database add a column those those
kinds of things don't don't necessarily
work very well once I have a large
important system in production so first
thing we have to worry about is how do
we ensure that if I need to run the
script twice that's the the results only
happen once how to make sure my scripts
are idempotent well sometimes we can
rely on the the migration script to be
inside of a transaction so some
databases support transactional DML that
is if something goes wrong it'll
actually roll back the changes to your
database but not all the time so a
roundhouse does run every single script
in a transaction but there's some
changes that you need to make they
cannot be completely combined and set
one single transaction and there's some
cases like just something went wrong I
don't know why and I just have to like
fiddle with again and make it run again
so one of the things that we can do is
do like a check if exists sort of query
that is when I run the migration script
if it don't just blindly try to make
changes but actually check to see if
that thing exists first before I
actually affect the change so here's an
example of looking for a table that
exists and for this you kind of have to
dig into whatever the the schema
definitions and views could be for your
individual database so some things
support this standard view of
information schema some don't what I
want to do is just say check to see if
the database in this case the table
already exists and if it does exist then
just like there's nothing to do don't
actually run the migration otherwise
that doesn't exist so let's do this
I can also look at the column
information to say well the table exists
but I needed to add a new column so I
can check the information sceeto schema
column table I'm going to do a similar
kind of thing with a stored procedure
this
makes check to see if the store
procedure exists and if it doesn't exist
then go ahead and perform the migration
so looking at the different kinds of
migrations that I run through there's
basically two kinds of changes I'm
making to my database there's ones where
it actually affects the the state and
the database so it's affecting the DML
I'm running is affecting affecting
components that actually have some state
involved fit or it could be something
that's completely stateless that has no
state involved in that change whatsoever
when I do stateful changes though I do
want to ensure that my changes that I'm
committing include both schema and the
data migrations so if I'm adding columns
or things like that then as part of that
exact same script I'll include whatever
data migrations are going to be
necessary along with it and the idea is
that if there's something that goes
wrong it's just that one commit that
includes all the changes as a part of it
as opposed to trying to split things up
and manage them separately no what about
stateless changes these are a bit easier
than stateful changes like with the
state let's change our stateful change
like adding refactoring database tables
or adding columns things like that I
think those gonna have a pretty big
impact but stateless changes should be
relatively straightforward to do there's
a couple different ways you could
approach this these are typically like
let's see indexes functions store
procedures these are the things that
have any kind of state behind the scenes
associated with them they're just either
they're kind of some kind of procedural
logic or something that's on top of your
actual State itself so one approach I've
seen is they just a drop and create so
drop the thing first if it exists and
then when you're done just go ahead and
create it all over again that way with
this drop and create I can run this
script multiple times as I'm testing it
out locally and then when I get to the
actual migration script then it should
run successfully there's better ways to
do this these days now if you're running
sequel 2016 or later or sequel Azure or
Hurley postgrads Postgres since forever
you have these create or update or
create or alter statements so in this
case it's it will it will create a new
store procedure if it doesn't
but if the procedure does exist then
we'll just alter this procedure in place
so these days
hopefully you're running in the you know
later version of the database and they
can use these kind of statements as well
now the way the migration tool treats
these scripts around house
it has scripts that can run only one
time so those are my schema migrations
it says basically you can run that one
time and you can never change that file
ever again but these kinds I can
actually run them multiple times so the
way that Roundhouse treats us it
actually will have a special folder
sprach slums indexes where I have these
kinds of files in there and instead of
me having migrations of the stored
procedure over time actually just to
define it once in that file and then
it's gonna just keep editing the file
over and over again the radio gate tool
does a similar kind of thing where has
migration scripts for DML but for
procedures and functions you just you
just basically edit those things in
place and it will generate the Creator
ultra statement for you now there are
some kind of exotic refactorings that
you can do as part of migrating your
schema so we see things like renaming a
table typically there's like four
depending on the database there's a
special way to do that kind of operation
so in this case we're gonna use a
special stored procedure to rename my
table in place so I just use the SP
underscore rename stored procedure
rename the person table to student in
this case now a lot of times I can't
easily fit migrations into just like one
single step and we especially see this
when I start to have lots and lots of
data as part of that table and so for
those you start to see migration splits
out into multiple stages or multiple
steps because I can't easily just
accomplish that with like one single go
I have to split that into multiple steps
so what a good example is splitting a
column this is by one of the few
examples I could actually find like
usually you just normalize this from the
get-go just you know humor me for a
second here let's say I was dumb enough
to put the entire name inside of one
column and I want to migrate that into
having those two names as separate
single columns as part of the database
hopefully we got some like easy way to
do that based on the text as part of it
but the way we'll do this is first we
want to we want to create those new
columns as part of that table so we have
execute one statement that will add
those two new columns for first-name and
lastname
the second part will have some kind of
migration step that will migrate the
data from the existing column into the
new sets of columns and then finally
we'll clean up after ourselves and
remove that previous column or may just
delete the column altogether now
splitting a table is a little bit more
challenging so in this case we've got
we've added like more and more columns
on top of it that represent additional
information and we get to the point
where like oh this is this isn't
normalized enough so we actually need to
split these out into two different
tables so this is a little bit more
challenging than the previous one where
it was just like in place be able to
split that one column into two so in
this case we have to attack it a little
bit separately
the first thing we're going to do is
create a new schema for those new set
that new table that exists over to the
side then we'll go ahead and migrate the
data from the existing table into that
new set of tables and then the last step
is then to remove all of those old
comments all old columns so it's the
same kind of pattern where I create the
new schema migrate the data and remove
the old stuff as I go through now with
all of these kinds of changes there's
you're introducing the possibility that
your application is actually broken for
a split second so you saw previously
when I did the deployment I deployed the
application in one step and then the
second step was in deploying the
database migrations but what happens if
the first step succeeds and then the
second step fails what do i do then well
some migration utilities have this
concept of up migrations and down
migrations
but because I'm including both the
application change and the sequel
scripts inside the same code base to get
pushed out at the same time it's not
actually easy to perform a down
migration if the application has already
been deployed so in those cases what I
typically handle it is
to have a new commit that is going to
roll back the previous set of changes to
get back into a good known States so and
know and those in that kind of manner
it's only term is you only roll forward
you never roll back will have a new
commit the fix is the thing that I just
broke and that I can go on from there
but these come all into like this this
overall umbrella of migrations at a much
larger scale so if I can't fit if making
these kinds of changes to my database
will just bring it down for potentially
long amount of time that I can't use the
same kind of techniques that I used in
much smaller or even much more less user
focused sort of systems so the user is
not like if I have play the ability to
bring the system down at a certain point
in time like well we're just gonna go
down Friday at midnight where no one's
logged in and it's not a big deal well
we can do that one of the things they
found though is that if you're making if
you're making these kinds of migration
scripts against the local database that
has like no rows in it things go pretty
fast if they start to make these changes
in production databases that have a lot
of data in it then it could take a very
very long time and one of the first
things that one of the first frustrating
things I found was that if I'm making a
migration of some schema that's gonna
affect a lot of rows and I just hit and
it just hits go I have literally no idea
how long it's gonna take to complete
like there is no progress bar on adding
an index to a table with a million rows
or billion rows like you're just gonna
start churning and then you just gotta
wait and wait and wait until the thing
finished and sometimes doing those kinds
of changes prevent and when anyone else
from using the system because they can
lock the entire table wired to
performance operation so ideally if I'm
now finally in production at a large
enough scale
I want to enable zero downtime changes
that as I make changes to my database
and application without bringing
anything down along the process but to
do so is going to be much more
challenging and difficult than our
normal integration stuff so we actually
to think about the changes is going to
make figure out the actual impact of
those changes and build on a plan of how
we're going to affect those changes in
production
so there's a lot of different techniques
out there one of the ones I really like
described was from stripe and they
described how they do their online
migrations at scale and they built all
these tools to help do that sort of
thing as well but the way you have to do
it is with a much more deliberate
incremental process where you're not
just migrating the schema all once but
you go through these very small changes
very small steps to be able to get your
change out into production so let's say
I want to do that change and why I had
before which is I have one table with
with like five columns and I want to
normalize that so that it's going to be
two tables well I can't just like just
roll out that change all at once because
it could be a billion rows that it's
affecting all at once and trying to get
that in one single like deployment is
just going to be too much work so we can
break this down into a much more step by
step process the first step we're going
to do is to perform a dual writing step
in this case what we're going to do is
modify our application code to instead
of just writing to the initial table
we're gonna have it right to both data
stores at the same time so as I write
the information for my alias in one
table I'm at the same time going to
write that alias and the other table now
the challenge with this approach is you
have to be very very sure that your gift
you found all the right paths in your
application and for a lot of legacy
legacy systems that I see there's like
an untold number of right paths because
you know it's legacy system so it's like
anyone can change anything at any time
or they've tried to just like stuff
everything in store procedures and hope
that it you know I figured it out there
but it's really hard to analyze those
kinds of paths so one option I've seen
work successfully or us is use the T
word which is a trigger feel like every
time you write this thing here just go
ahead and write it over there as well
and when they advantages here is it
still participates in the database
transaction so ensures that if like
something doesn't get written then it
can roll the transaction back and both
sides of the equation are still going to
be okay now this this is kind of a
precarious middle step because now I've
got two sources of truth so I do want to
make sure that I don't have anything
except that explicit an integration path
that's writing to my second database
table and I have to worry about what
about all that existing data I've got
one row here but what if
what if I've got that billion rows of
data for all these names and aliases how
do i how do I migrate that information
for all the kind of back history going
on there so the right path only take
care of new data so new rights going in
yes I can have it go to the other path
but for all that existing data I have to
have so I just figure out what am I
going to do with all this so I need to
figure out what is going to be my
strategy for getting that data from
where it is today to where it needs to
be and honestly one of the one of the
solutions could be just do nothing like
you just don't care about the old data
that it's only for new data going
forward or you can say I'm going to go
ahead and and and copy all the data from
the existing database tables into the
new tables now this is probably not
something you want to do all at once
because again if you're trying to do a
single update statement from an existing
one like where I'm inserting a billion
rows that could take absolutely forever
so we all often do is try to split that
into individual batches now this may
take a long time but what I'm trying not
to do is have a transaction that's open
it's like a week instead if I do like
you know a certain set of Records at a
time maybe a thousand or ten thousand
then I'm reducing this the transactional
load on my destination table we want to
make sure too that we don't accidentally
overwrite data so oftentimes we'll run
this a couple times to make sure we
didn't miss anything
and that's we've we've got all the great
data into the right spot okay so now
that we've got our right paths figured
out which still could take a long time
like this step I've seen take like three
months to figure out all the places that
are being changed and how do how to get
all them writing over to the correct
location well do things like run run
true-up reports that compare the data in
a second table with the first stay at
the table and see if there's any
discrepancies and any places we need to
then go fix once we've got that in place
though and we're reasonably sure we've
got basically two identical sources of
truth then we can update the read paths
to point to the new source of truth
which is this new table so this case I'm
updating any kind of queries that are
going to my existing table but a
modifying all the repass my application
to
read from the new set of tables as
opposed to the old set of tables and
this can also be done incrementally I've
done this like one read at a time where
I I changed one look one path from the
old table to the new table
release that into production run my
troop reports see if there's any
discrepancies and then do the next the
next the next the next the more
incremental we can do this migration the
the less risk we'll have in the overall
migration so now that if once I've got
that that that reasonable certainty that
I've fixed all the right paths and fixed
all the repass now we can update the
right path to only write to the new set
of tables so the application is now no
now wholly dependent on the new set of
tables for its information at this point
I have a few choices sometimes what I've
done is then reverse the previous arrow
where the new table will have triggers
that write back to the old table to
ensure that if there's just something
out there that's still looking at my old
stuff it won't just completely break but
eventually I want to sever all those
connections to the old information then
the last piece of the puzzle is to
remove the old information from that
legacy set of information for that
legacy set of columns or tables so this
is the point where you're basically
you're just like you're just deleting
the columns out of the database and
everything should then be using all
these new paths now we want to we will
make sure we have data integrity checks
at each step of the way so this is this
is often very customized where I'm
running counts and discrepancies and
looking at heuristics to see how
everything matches up but if everything
looks green and everything's 100% match
then I should be able to make make the
move to the next step in the process
now what about very very large table
migrations let's say I'm just making a
very small or change to this system
that's affecting this overall table so I
break this up into individual steps as
well first step will be to create a new
table with the new schema then I batch
fill the new table with all the old
information and then I rename
the old table - the new table so
basically I'm like doing a swap this is
kind of a Bluegreen deployment for
database tables where I create a new
table to the side fill with all the
information and then swap it for the old
table and now I've got a new table with
all the new information ready to go
there's a lot of different techniques
you can use here as well I've seen
people as well like create new
partitions or file groups for the new
table information so I'm not even
affecting it all the existing underlying
hardware that the the existing database
is running on very often with things
like indexes can totally screw up the
performance of your system as it's
trying to build this index of a billion
rows so you may want to create that off
to the side and then when the time is
ready and it's done then you go ahead
and connect it to the existing database
so these are all the techniques I've
used for relational databases this this
is one of those things that you don't
really know or care about until you hit
into production and then it's like
release night and all my god so I do
want to really caution folks like you
should as you're doing these kind of
database migrations do keep in mind what
you're actually changing in production
to understand what is gonna be the
potential impact as you do that and so
we'll do like dry runs of these
migrations as well well we'll have a
prod backup then we run Ryan's and grits
migration migrations against first that
have like an exact replica of what we
see in production to get an idea of like
oh this this one is actually going to
take longer than X amount of time so we
need to rethink how we're going to do
this migration to ensure that it's going
to complete within the SLT SLA that
we're trying to affect but what about no
sequel what about databases that don't
have a schema and for a lot of the
systems that I run that run no sequel
databases it's very easy to develop
these kind of systems locally because I
have to worry about schema migrations at
all right I just like I just keep coding
and changing the shape of things and
coding a change in the size shape of
things and everything works until you
like release it in production and make
some change that breaks by schema and so
I have this like range of emotions that
I go through like disbelief craziness
like you know crying oh my god what am I
gonna do now and then like just banging
my head in the table what how could I
possibly solve this problem because I
was promised that there was no sequel
there's no schema but there's a schema
it's just somewhere else it's in your
code which is much harder to track down
changes to and modifications and much
more difficult to track those changes
over time so the first thing to look at
is one do I even need to migrate data so
this is not no sequel migration
strategies and that's something I
typically put into place at the
beginning of a project but I do find
that in no sequel databases especially
like document databases it's really not
unlike other kinds of documents that I'm
working with like API documents the JSON
documents I've returned for web api's
for messages like I stick on some kind
of a MTP or RabbitMQ and it's just still
Jason right so can I apply the same kind
of techniques I have for those kinds of
messages and documents to my document
store we also find that people are
typically doing no sequel in a micro
service kind of environment and so in
this case I've got some kind of like
insurance system that I've converted to
micro services in which each step of the
overall process for issuing an
application for insurance is broken up
into its own individual service and in
this case I've got different databases
for different kinds of needs so if I'm
choosing the right database for the job
that's not necessarily always going to
be a no sequel database so in our case
we had the initial step in the process
which was the sales application well
that sales application had data that
changed that that needed to be kept over
a long period of time so the sales
database was like Salesforce or
something and they they kept up those
sales databases for years and years and
years but the middle part of the
application that is much more kind of
not as long-running more short-lived
kind of data so once they perform each
of these steps they don't really need to
keep that data anymore it's like I've
done the thing I don't you know and then
my step is done I just toss that
information out the door but then I
typically have some final step which is
in receiving the results of all these
intermediate operations and
that becomes like the more traditional
schema full kind of database so if you
do need to migrate there have a few
options we have it or at our disposal
the first is just to migrate on read
that is when we read the document out of
the database we check to see if it's at
some specific version and then execute
some some code based on I need to
migrate this from one point to the next
this I found is pretty valuable because
I don't I only really care about
migrating the data when I need to use it
again and so if I migrate it when I read
the information back out that lets me
just more incrementally and on-the-fly
migrate my documents from one point to
the next sometimes I can't always do
that when you do it more in bulk and so
we can migrate using a tool and the tool
that I like to use a tool called node
migrates so it is it is node based or
NPM based but it's still very easy to
automate and basically I write my
migrations with JavaScript and very
similar to I had the schema migrations
I'm loading a document out of the
database check and is checking its
version and then performing whatever
kind of in-memory change I need to and
then that document is then persisted to
the database again or I just don't do we
actually need do we actually need to
need this kind of migration so one of
the things that we found in our no
sequel databases is there's no sequel
databases we've really for short lived
data but then the business was looking
at it saying like we want to run reports
on MongoDB which like don't do that by
the way like [ __ ] is not built for
reports instead well we what I'm doing
is creating a migration process in which
we separated out transactional short lit
of information from historical
information and the way we would push
those changes out is either through
messaging eventing or triggers so that
as someone made changes to the
transactional database we actually spit
out some kind of messages say someone
has done this thing that would go
through an ETL process and then that
would finally go into a data warehouse
where the business could actually run
reports on it so if I can get away with
just like not doing migrations that'd be
better right like just one less thing
for me to do so it did take some
convincing from the business to be able
to have this kind of picture where I'm
not allowing them to look to look and
report off my existing database
and then having a very specific set of
controlled output that they can didn't
put into the data warehouse which in
that point that is actually versioned
and and uses migrations and so for us we
actually just get rid of all data like
once the once one of these steps is
finished for an overall application we
actually don't care about that data
anymore so we have these we have these
cleanup steps that just get rid of all
data that says we don't need the
underwriting application information
from two weeks ago because we issued the
thing so just go ahead and delete it so
some parting thoughts here see ICD with
databases is not only possible but it is
necessary if we want to be able to have
the same kinds of X agile delivery with
our databases as we do with our code
then we have to institute a very similar
kind of process that we have with our
code as with our database it does
require a lot more thought in planning
because databases are stateful not
stateless I do actually have to think
about how I'm going to take that
database from one step to the next
mistakes are gonna be a lot more costly
of course so we want to apply techniques
that allow to us also very incrementally
take our application and database from
one step to the next and we can make
these little bitty baby steps overall
that allows us to actually go a lot
faster my final recommendation is to
learn your DBAs whisky preference
because you will need to bribe them on
these techniques and tools so anything
do you like help smooth things over with
them and don't make an ending of them
because again their skills are actually
much more valuable than yours because
they have the data so do become their
friend
so that was CIN CD with databases or for
databases this application is actually
gonna be on my github so we want to
check out a full running example I'll
have it up there otherwise they go for
coming and have a great rest of the
conference
[Applause]